vous en êtes où alors vous avez quitté
votre dernier post
oui soyons honnêtes vous avez menti sur
votre âge n'ont vraiment rien à voir je
pense que j'arrive à voir au delà de ça
remet ça commence un petit peu mal pour
le coup ça c'est vous qui savez qu'est
ce qui vous a poussé à présenter votre
candidature chez nous l'instinct dans
quelle mesure pensez-vous être le
candidat idéal
oui d'accord très bien
bon allez alors quels sont vos points
forts piloter en caleçon et de faire
venir une hôtesse pour qu'elle apporte à
café je suis pas sûr qu'il faille
rentrer dans des détails trop spécifique
ne m'envoyez pas quels sont vos rapports
avec la hiérarchie pour moi et doit être
belle
comme vous comme j'imagine non tapotant
dunant est ce que vous considérez comme
quelqu'un d'autonome malheureusement oui
allez je vous prends pour le coup je
pense qu'il est encore un peu tôt
convergent
[Musique]